talk about mixing business with pleasure
it's a beautiful thing courtney
kardashian calls herself travis barker's
quote tour wife as she joins him for a
performance with machine gun kelly
during a stop in indianapolis
the mom of three shares behind the scene
snaps of travis's performance and some
intimate shots along with him backstage
on instagram
including this one showing the two
leaning in for a kiss
and the two lovebirds holding hands
ahead of showtime
[Music]
with pride courtney captions the post
quote to our wife travis of course
doesn't shy away from showing his love
on social media and responds in the
comments with quote tore life's better
with you i've never met
a better human in my life court's son
mason also makes an appearance as she
shows off their choice of shoes for the
tour plus her man's digs backstage and
more video of the packed out stadium
during travis and mgk's epic performance
it's always amazing courtney joining
travis comes just one month after she
joined the 46 year old musician when he
gave a surprise performance at mgk's
mainstream sellout show at the forum in
los angeles
marking his first on stage appearance
since being hospitalized for
pancreatitis in june
but it's no surprise that travis hopped
back on stage for his buddy mgk kravis's
friendship with mgk and his fiancee
megan fox seems to have grown stronger
since the couple attended court and
travis's wedding in italy in may
and megan recently suggested she and
court should start and only fans
following the release of these sexy
behind-the-scenes polaroid pics from
their skin shoe we're just you know
living our best lives and
yeah
now on to what could be next for
courtney and travis
following travis's health scare a source
told et last month that they are quote
stronger than ever
with another source also revealing that
the couple is not giving up on expanding
their family court and travis were open
about their fertility journey on season
one of the kardashians saying quote
having a baby together is still an
ongoing conversation but travis's health
is top priority
i do love being a mom i think
having that experience with travis would
just be incredible i know he's a really
really amazing father it's one of the
reasons that i fell in love with him the
ups and downs courtney and travis have
faced in their pursuit to have a baby of
their own is something the pooch founder
touched on when chatting with e.t back
in april what has it been like to be on
the path to baby with travis i think
it's
been
i mean it's a beautiful thing that we'd
love to have happen um but
you know the journey is a bit hard for
any women who've been on it and
emotional
[Music]